In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 10th, on which we commemorate the most pious
empress, Pulcheria.
The memory of the most pious empress, Pulcheria, who died in peace.
And Pulcheria was the sister of Emperor Thodosios II in the years 408 to 450.
On the death of Arcadia's, the administration of the empire, felt to her, although she was
only 15 years old.
She saw to it that the young Thodosius and his two other sisters, Arcadia and Maria, were
brought up in godliness and modesty.
She encouraged her sisters to remain in lifelong virginity as she did herself.
On the death of Thodosios, she married the Emperor Marcian in the years 450 through 457.
A good man, a no longer young, with whom she lived in chastity, with the same love of godliness
and the same dedication to the church.
Throughout her life, she expended the most part of her wealth in charitable works and was
a zealous builder of churches, hospitals, orphanages and monasteries.
Her zeal in preserving the purity of the Orthodox faith was just as ardent.
The fourth ecumenical council met at Calcedon in her reign to anathematize utikis and the
monophysites, and during its sessions she took her place with Marcian in the midst of the
Holy Fathers.
She died in peace at the age of 54, in the year 453 through the prayers of our Holy Fathers
O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.